[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking back in from the
Museum of curiosity season 9 it's in the
books and you know what time it is it is
time to answer your hard-hitting season
9 fan questions we reached out on
Twitter we reached out on Instagram we
reached out here on YouTube and these
are the questions the spice Lords need
answered
so without wasting any more time
Christopher bring me the burger show hat
with the fan questions here we go
another round from Contreras 1337 is
your most underrated episode still trick
daddy or is there a new underdog while
Trick Daddy is forever and always the
most underrated episode of hot ones but
in the spirit of this question here it
is my definitive list of the top 10 most
underrated hot ones episodes ever in no
particular order and my only criteria is
that they have below 3 million views so
here it is
top 10 most underrated first Alexa Chung
Jesus and Mero Artie Lange Henry Rollins
Tom Arnold Danny Brown Joe Budden nori
Redman and with my last spot keke palmer
keke palmer that's the below 3 million
most underrated episodes club loved
those episodes watch them let's get
those let's get those out let's get
those out views up all right
next what has been your favorite place
to travel for an interview love it
whenever we get a chance to go to London
a few years ago the hot ones team went
out to London in like three days we shot
with Charlie sloth Ricky Gervais Russell
Brand and it really galvanized us as a
team and then this season we got a
chance to go back and shoot with Idris
Elba which is obviously a super fun
experience so to answer your question
London whenever I get a chance to go to
London I love it
alright into the Hat we go more
questions more questions please no more
pseudo famous rappers who only be
relevant for a few months
all right happy to address this you know
it seems that who gates they've joined
forces with haterville and uh you know
you can't police the Internet I
understand that but I you know we're
about to go into season ten and I can't
bite my lip forever you know we've had
the Jonas Brothers Trevor Noah
Halle Berry Aubrey Plaza the stranger
things kids followed by a Kristen Bell
and Idris Elba and Stone Cold Steve
Austin and I was on Jimmy Fallon smoking
out Selena Gomez and Jimmy so that's uh
that's like the past like twelve weeks
and still our Instagram comments will be
like where are the guests or if you
respond to that they're like they're
like they're like yeah well earlier this
year you had a rapper who I have never
heard of what the [ __ ] and at some point
I don't know you just got you just gotta
be like uh I don't know what to say
I don't know what to say alright what
was your favorite 90s Nickelodeon
cartoon I was a big doug guy that was a
big Rugrats guy I was a big ren and
stimpy guy but you know what as a kid
born in 86 it's not always just about
the cartoons with Nickelodeon and no one
asked but here is my Mount Rushmore of
Nickelodeon shows you ready all that The
Adventures of Pete and Pete guts and
duck put it in stone all right favorite
video game of all time I love these
questions favorite video game top 5 dead
or alive we gotta go Madden we gotta go
Goldeneye we gotta go twisted metal we
gotta go Mario Kart and we gotta go
Grand Theft Auto video game top 5 dead
or alive
alright back in the half we go who is
your favorite guest this season and why
for me personally looking back it was a
fun one to shoot it's hard not to fall
in love with injure selva and i'll tell
you a funny Idris Elba's story you know
like we shot that episode in London
and I'm chillin in the lobby at the Four
Seasons there in London and it's a
couple hours before the shoot and I'm
just going over my notes you know doing
all the doing all the preflight checks
you know are there any holes in the
setup here any blind spots in the run of
show just looking through it Coleman
making sure and then out of the corner
of my eye I see it just Alba walking
towards me and you know I'm not I'm not
one of the you know I'm not gonna be
like hey address I'm Sean from hot ones
I'll be interviewing you you know I let
people live I just let everybody live
their life so he's walking by and I'm
just kind of minding my business and he
stops and I look and he double takes at
me and he points right at me and goes
I'm ready and that's when I knew it
would be a great shoot and it was so
much fun hot ones it's always its best
when like we have a guest who's into a
bunch of different little things and
then with every wing we're taking a
layer off of that onion he was just
shoulders relaxed like one of the
interviews that were probably most proud
of not just this season but in the
history of the show another fun fact is
afterwards we both got sauce in our eyes
I think the room the air conditioning
was broken it was like 150 degrees just
sweating bullets and both of us
afterwards were just boom like that and
then he had to go to a premiere and I
had to go to a cold shower and that is
the the hot ones post game show with
injure Salva honorable mention Stone
Cold Steve Austin he was a lot of fun
when he was in here it's a lot of fun
whenever that guys around so stone cold
an address those are my two favorites
all right if for some reason you were
not able to do the interview yourself
which previous guests would you like to
come in as a guest host
that's a great question off the top of
my head Bert Kreischer could probably
come in cold off the street and hold
down the fort here at hot ones Trevor
Noah
would be a great host but my opinion on
the matter does not really matter Chris
Shawn burger which former guest would
you give a formal offer to replace me
okay okay
let's say through some YouTube nonsense
your channel gets deleted and you can't
do it anymore what do you do well if
that's the case you know what I think I
do I think I moved back to Chicago and I
try to get I try to get one of those
daily morning shows like one of those 10
a.m. Windy City live shows and I'm just
sipping out of a coffee mug and reading
the headlines and wearing a stupid suit
and just kind of putting it on cruise
control that's what I would love to do
and if not that campus cop campus cop
all right getting towards the bottom of
the bucket here why do you have the
Detroit hell fire rated at 65,000
Scoville but according to the bottle it
ranges from a hundred thousand to three
hundred thousand this is a great
question and funny story it's a question
that was brought to us by the Detroit
Free Press is there a fact-checking an
article they called us up and they said
hey we're doing this article the bottle
says one hundred to three hundred you
show says sixty-five what's the deal and
we investigated it further and it turns
out we [ __ ] up that's what happens we
[ __ ] it up
sometimes we [ __ ] it up sometimes we
[ __ ] it up and then our rule on fuck-ups
is if we [ __ ] it up you got to just
ride that [ __ ] out most most
productions they would try to fix their
fuck-ups this we rock with them baby all
right Sean
imagine you have three interviews set up
in one day you're getting scorched on
hot ones or getting drunk with nori on
drink champs and you're getting high
with snoop on GGN what order do you do
the interviews that question is from
destroy and it's the best fan question
I've ever been asked and it's a it's a
good question let me think this through
all right so I think the way you do it
is this I think yes start on drink
champs loosen you up for hot ones then
you go to hot ones sober you up a little
bit and then you smoke it all down on
GGN with Snoop I think that's the only
way to go I'm doing the math all right
one more question did you expect this
show to grow as big as the show has and
what are your plans for the future if
given an unlimited budget alright that's
a great question and we asked people
who've made the transition from
- TV all the time whether it's the girls
from broad city whether it's ISA ray
alright
Wow that you know now you've got a bag
and you can do different things like
what did you do differently and for us
we think about that sometimes I don't
know you know what the occasional the
occasional first-class flight for crying
out loud you know listen this is an
email Chris give me my phone and Chris
is back this is an email I sent earlier
today earlier today from seat from road
26 seat B I sent this question earlier
subject line is mint or bust and then
the body of my email is not coming back
to NYC on that red-eye unless my seat
reclines into a twin bed that's what I
said so that would be nice you know I'm
bouncing around all over all over the
country even outside of the country get
my passport stamped and I'm doing it all
from the from the seat right before the
head caching kitchen wash and whatever
comes out of there well uh well I'm a
blonde squeezed with my elbows inside of
my knees alright
that's no fun but to answer your
question for real for real I don't think
we could do I don't think you could put
money into hot ones and make the show
better I think you know we need this
stripped-down set because we have to
travel all over the place to do this
show so I don't think if we you know in
here's the other thing too this pushes
us creatively when we have no budget
when we're still on a shoestring it
pushes us creatively and then ultimately
we can just focus on the guests and on
the interview and not on the bells and
whistles or whatever so to answer your
question you know they could give us
more money I don't even know what we'd
do with it
nothing it wouldn't make the show better
we'd we'd say thank you
and we'd seal back the suitcase and we'd
push it back across the conference table
and say no no no no no thank you
all right well there you have it the Hat
it's empty thank you so much to the fans
who submitted questions and have now
rocked with us their seasons 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and into 10 and the coming weeks
between now and then lots of surprises
hot sauce reveal a truth of DAB maybe a
reunion episode maybe some other special
surprises only time will tell
keep it locked - first we feast in
season 10 it's just around the corner
baby we'll see you then ha thank you
thank you hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in with
a very exciting hot sauce update our
first ever collaborative sauce it's here
88 rising first we feast joining forces
to make dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something what we're
super proud of if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
it can fly away
[Music]
you